Alex formosi crossed 100 million dollars
in net worth by age 32. so I asked him
what most people get wrong about
starting a business and his advice was
surprisingly straightforward and I think
the big problem is that people expect
that they're going to have a perfect
business I can't think of an
entrepreneur beside Chef Bezos who's a
freak of nature most people have a
graveyard of failures behind them the
idea is you start not with the intent of
saying this is going to be the one thing
for the rest of my life which is the
fallacy that employees have when in
relatives I just have to do a thing that
I'm good enough at that I can learn the
game and the thing is once you start
taking steps The Next Step becomes
illuminated you trying to think a
hundred steps into the future when you
have no context is irrelevant because
chaos is going to break your plan and a
lot of people think they need to have
some novel idea the best way to start a
business is just look at what everyone
else is doing and just try and do it
better what are things that I already
know how to do or I have past experience
in what things because I have past
experience I know that other people
struggle with that sucks about this
thing and then I will solve that
specific problem and it could also be a
problem that other people solve too you
just try and do a little bit better
thank you